COMMITTEE ON RULES TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M GOING TO
MAKE SEVERAL ANOUNCEMENTS TODAY
TOO AGAIN EXPLAIN OUR PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE
OUR ESSENTIAL WORK. DURING THE
PANDEMIC FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
REALLYAPPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT ONE MORE
TIME FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE TUNING
IN FOR THE FIRST TIME. SO LET ME
GO AHEAD AND COVER THE TECHNICAL
SIDE OF THINGS FOR TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC OUR SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING. MADE NEXT
YEAR JUST MONTHS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND THE
SAFETY OF PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. ON OUR WEBSITE AND
WE MAY DISPLAYED A ANOTHER TIME
OR TWO FOR THE PUBLIC'S. BENEFIT
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
OUR COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU SO WE THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE OUR HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LACTAM FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THESE NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO PLEASE BE PATIENT AGAIN
EVERYONE SO WE- CAN HEAR YOU AND
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER I'M
GOING TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY
COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES A LIGHT
SPEAKS SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. AND
FORGIVE ME IF I HAD TO INTERRUPT
YOU IF IT MEANS I JUSTWANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET YOUR
TESTIMONY- I MAY HAVE TO ASK YOU
TO SLOW DOWN OR OR TALK. MORE
CLEARLY SO FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE
IF I END UP HAVING TO DO THAT.
IT'S ONLY BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET
YOUR TESTIMONY. SO AS WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO AS A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU'LL
NEED TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
FOR THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME
WE VOTE. SIX THIS CALL. HERE
HERE KAMLAGER HERE I'M LONGER
HERE LAYARD FAITH YOUR FAITH
HERE ATKINS HERE HAPPENS HERE
THANK YOU AND FOR THE PUBLIC LET
ME LET YOU KNOW THAT US SENATOR
LAYERED IS PRESENTING A BILL HE
WILL BE HERE SO HE WILL BE HERE
TODAY- BUT I WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD- WITH
. BACK TO OUR FIRST GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEEAND GET SOME ODD
CONSENT ITEMS HOPEFULLY OUT OF
THE WAY. I'M GOING TO ASK IF ARE
MY COLLEAGUES WOULD MAKE A
MOTION UNDER ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE HAVE. TO
SEE D. E. N. F. AND THOSE ARE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR CALM WATER HAS MOVED
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE RIGHT GROW.
KAMLAGER I NO LONGER I'D LAYERED
FAITH ALL RIGHT BATES AYE ATKINS
HI ADNAN SYED THANK YOU AND
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ARE ON CALL FOR
SENATOR LAYERED WHEN HE RETURNS
I WOULD ASK FOR OF A MOTION FOR
ITEM NUMBER THREE REFERRAL OF
BILLS SO MOVED. THANK YOU- I
WILL LET SENATOR GROWTH MAKE
THAT MOTION OP MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HI GROW FIVE KAMLAGER HI I'M
LONGER I'D LAYERED FAITH RIGHT
BATES AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS BY
ON CALL ON CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
US SENATOR LAYERED. AND WITH
THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHT AND
THAT'S GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR- ITEM NUMBER
ONE A IS THE APPOINTMENT OF MS
ELIZABETH A HIDE IT. JD AS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. LET ME SAY
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- I WILL INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT IS WITH
YOU OR THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. OUR AND THEN IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS- PLEASE GO AHEAD AND DO
THAT AND AFTER THAT
INTRODUCTION- I WILL GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ATKINS A
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
APPEAR TODAY. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH HEADACHE AND I WISH TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY HUSBAND AT. AND
OUR THREE DAUGHTERS TESS WHO IS
A NURSE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
GRACED HER BUSHES FOR MGM AND LA
IN INTERNATIONAL TV AND THEIR
YOUNGEST FRANCESCA WHO'S
FINISHING HER BACHELOR'SDEGREE.
IN FASHION DESIGN. N. F. I. T.
IN NEW YORK. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOR HAVING CONFIDENCE IN
ME. AND APPOINTING ME AS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK SECRETARY
RICHARDSON AND THE GOVERNOR
ABSENT TEAM AND ESPECIALLY
DIRECTOR PAOLO. FOR THEIR
GUIDANCE DURING THIS PROCESS.
THEY HAVE ALONG WITH MY FAMILY
HAVE PROVIDED ME TREMENDOUS
SUPPORT FOR WHICH I AM DEEPLY
GRATEFUL. EACH YEAR L. A. L.
WITH ITS SMALL DEDICATED STAFF
OF TWENTY THREE EMPLOYEES
PREVIOUS THOUSANDS OF
REGULATIONS PROPOSED BY HUNDREDS
OF STATE AGENCIES. FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE SUBSTANTIVE
AND PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
. SOME OF THOSE RULEMAKINGS COME
WITH BANKERS BOXES TOTALING
FORTY OR MORE OF SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION AND A REVEALING
ATTORNEY HAS THIRTY DAYS. OR TEN
DAYS FOR AN EMERGENCY ROOM
MAKING. TO REVIEW AND EITHER
RECOMMEND APPROVAL OR
DISAPPROVAL OF THAT SUBMISSION.
I'VE PERSONALLY REVIEWED OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MATTERS
FOR THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW. ALL A. L. ALSO PUBLISHES
THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS AND I NOTICED
REGISTER AND WE REVIEW OF
PETITIONS SUBMITTED BY THE
PUBLIC CHALLENGING STATE AGENCY
ACTIONS AS POTENTIAL UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS. WE PROVIDE
EXTENSIVE TRAINING TO STATE
AGENCIES WITH RESPECT TO HOW TO
DO WILL GROW MAKING AND ALSO HOW
TO IDENTIFY WHAT MUST BE ADOPTED
PURSUANT TO THE APA OR.
UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS. NEXT
WEEK WE WILL ALSO HAVE A PUBLIC
INFORMATION CENTRES SESSION FOR
THE GENERAL PUBLIC. TO WILL HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN
MORE FULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
ROLE MAKING PROCESS WE AT O. A.
L. TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND A MATTER OF PUBLIC
TRUST. WE CAREFULLY REVIEW THOSE
ROAMING TWENTY SURE THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE HAVE BEEN
RESPECTED AND THAT'S THE
AGENCIES ARE STAYING WITHIN
THEIR DELEGATED AUTHORITY. IT
WAS WHEN I JOINED- A. L. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AFTER SEVEN YEARS
OF CIVIL LITIGATION PRACTICE
THAT I FOUND MY LEGAL PASSION.
THE MISSION OF AUDIO AND
PROTECING THE PUBLIC'S
PARTICIPATION IN THAT MISSION
CONTINUES TO BE A MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR ME. I CANNOT
THINK OF ANYTHING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO DO MORE. THAN TO
CONTINUE TO ADD- ANY L. AS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE FOR ME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M GOING TO TURN FIRST TO OUR
VICE CHAIR TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
. MISGUIDED I DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS I
WAS GOING TO BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
VERY IMPOLITE FOR ME TO LEAVE IN
THE MIDDLE OF YOUR ANSWER.
BECAUSE I AM VERY CHALLENGES ARE
WITH TIME I HAVE A PLANE TO
CATCH BUT I WANTED TO MENTION I
DID ONCE YOU. NEED TO LEAVE IT
OUT SHARE WITH YOU HOW IMPRESSED
I AM WITH YOUR FOCUSING YOUR
GOAL FROM THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. IN THE RULEMAKING
ISSUE BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
CONCERNED THAT WHEN LEGISLATION
IS PASSED AND RULES ARE MADE TO-
BY THE VARIOUS AGENCIES DIRECTED
BY THAT LEGISLATION. THAT THEY
ARE FOLLOWING THE INTENT. OF THE
LEGISLATION THE AUTHOR IN
CERTAINLY ON MY COLLEAGUES TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF MANY OF THESE
THINGS SO- I GIVE YOU THUMBS UP
IT IS THE GOVERNMENT OF BY AND
FOR THE PEOPLE AND IT SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE YOU ARE REALLY REALLY. A
GATE KEEPER ON THAT AND THAT IS
VERY IMPRESSIVESO YOU WILL HAVE
MY SUPPORT ABSOLUTELY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I THANK YOU TO MY VICE CHAIR
AND- APPRECIATE THAT YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE SO THANK YOU FOR MAKING
THOSE COMMENTS I HAD A TOP. LET
ME TURN TO YOU SENATOR CALM
WATER AND SEE IF YOU WANT TO GO
NEXT IF NOT I'M HAPPY TO. GO IN
ANY ORDER HERE ALL OF THE FIVE
GO HEAD THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND- THANK YOU FOR
AGREEING TO CONTINUE. TO SERVICE
HIDING I- APOLOGIES BECAUSE MY
SCHEDULE DIDN'T REALLY ALLOW FOR
US TO. TALK BEFOREHAND BUT I
READ THROUGH. YOUR RESUME IN THE
DOCUMENTS PROVIDED AND I THINK
YOU ARE IMMENSELY QUALIFIED- AND
WE ARE. INDEBTED TO YOU FOR
WANTING TO SERVE- YOU KNOW I
HAVE A QUESTION I NOTICED IN MY
READING THAT. SOMETIMES WE AS
LEGISLATORS WHEN WE ARE OFFERING
BILLS WE HAVE A CARVE OUT. OF
THE ATP APA PROCESS. AND YOU
KNOW WE WANTED TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS AND- BY DOING
THAT- WE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
CREATING MORE. UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS BY AVOIDING THE APA
ARE THERE WAYS THAT WE COULD
SORT OF. COURSE CORRECT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THEN- FOR YOUR
QUESTION- IF I KIND OF FELT I
ASSUME THAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO
EXEMPTIONS- AND YOU KNOW IT'S
TOTALLY WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE-
WHICH- AGENCIES IN WHICH
PROGRAMS WHICH PROCESSES SHOULD
BE. FOLLOWED PURSUANT TO THE APA
ON THAT IN AND OF ITSELF WOULD
NOT CREATE UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS BECAUSE- THAT
DECISION TO EXAM SOMETHING FROM
THE APA PROCESS MEANS. THAT THEY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THAT AND THAT
WOULD NOT AMOUNT TO AN
UNDERGROUND REGULATION WHICH
WOULD BE A STANDARD RULE OF
GENERAL APPLICATION. ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED BY A STATE AGENCY
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN GONE
THROUGH THE APA BUT DID NOT. AND
I AM NOT ANY SORT OF EXEMPTIONS
THE LEGISLATURE AN AXE WOULD NOT
MAKE THEM SUSCEPTIBLE. TO
UNDERGROUND REGULATION
CHALLENGES. THANK YOU THAT CLEAR
FOR- YOU KNOW I DON'T REALLY
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND HELPFUL I. I DO
THINK WE NEED ALL THE HELP WE
CAN GET IN- CREATING LAWS AND
POLICIES THAT ARE CLEAR. TO
UNDERSTAND YES AND THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE WAY IN WHICH
THEY WERE INTENDED. AND SO ANY
DEPARTMENT OR GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT CAN HELP US ACHIEVE THAT. I
SAY YES TO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THE UP
. THANK YOU SENATOR COME LONGER
US SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISS HIGH TECH HOW ARE YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU. I WAS VERY.
PLEASED WITH YOUR OPENING
REMARKS THAT'S WHERE MY
QUESTIONS HAD SURROUNDED- AND-
THE PARTICIPATION OF THE PUBLIC
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCESS. AND YOU ARE COVERED
THAT VERY WELL I ALSO CAN TELL
YOU THAT SITTING ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE- THIS IS PROBABLY
GONNA BE THE EASIEST
CONFIRMATION THAT I'VE SAT
THROUGH THEM I LOOK AT YOUR
BACKGROUND IN WHO YOU ARE AND-
THEN I LOOK AT YOUR LAW.
EXPERIENCE AND THE GREAT BALANCE
WHICH WE VERY RARELY HAPPENS IN
THESE CASES BUT YOUR BALANCE
THAT YOU BRING. SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS
THAT YOU DO OVERSEE AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT
IS. IS THERE AND- I JUST
APPRECIATE AND WHAT YOU'VE DONE
I WILL ASK ONE THING JUST FOR
THE PUBLIC- KNOWLEDGE CAN YOU
PLEASE- AB. TELL US ABOUT THE
TRAINING COURSES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OFFICE
ADMINISTRATION LAW PROVIDES ON
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS. FOR THE
EIGHTY EIGHT YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
AND YOU KNOW THE HAS THE BAND
PANDEMIC IMPACTED YOUR ABILITY
TO MEET THE GENERAL FUND
REQUIREMENT. AND IF SO ARE THERE
SOLUTIONS THAT YOU CAN AND- COME
UP WITH THAT MIGHT HELP US AND
GUIDE POLICY. SO WE HAVE
SWITCHED GEARS SAYS HI EVERY
STATE AGENCY SEEMS TO HAVE. AND
HAVE BEEN DOING TELECONFERENCE.
TRAININGS ARE THREE DAY RULE
MAKING TRAINING AS AN OPEN AND
WIDELY RESPECTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WE GO FROM NUTS AND BOLTS
BEGINNING TO END AND TRY TO HELP
AGENCIES DEMYSTIFIES THE PROCESS
AND TELL THEM WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO EVERY STEP OF THE WAY- AND
THEN WE HAVE A LOT OF
INTERACTIVE. EXERCISES TO HELP
THEM OUT SO THEN TRAINING HAS
CONTINUED REACTION. HUNTER AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHER STAFF STATE
AGENCY STAFF THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC- AND OUR STAFF IS AN
AMAZING DEDICATED GROUP OF
PEOPLE AND AS SOON AS A PANDEMIC
BECAME A LONG LASTING THING-
THEY SWITCHED GEARS AND ENGAGED
IN THAT TELECONFERENCE VIDEO
CONFERENCE- PROCESS AND WE'VE
GOTTEN GOOD FEEDBACK AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE THAT HAVE STAYED
UNDERGROUND REGULATION TRAINING
WHICH- WE HAVE ALSO CONTINUED
DURING THE PANDEMIC I DON'T
THINK WE MISSED ONE MONTH'S.
TRAINING FOR- DURING THIS TIME.
IT IS A CHALLENGE TO MEET THAT
COMMITMENT- THE BUDGET
COMMITMENTS BUT I HAVE SO FAR WE
HAVE DONE FINE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE.
WHY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE FOR SURROUNDING
TRAINING THAT THE TRAINING WAS
CONTINUING AND YOU ANSWER THAT I
APPRECIATE YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE- YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT PEOPLE OF
YOUR CALIBER AND WHO YOU ARE
WITH- ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS-
AND I IT BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
STANDING UP AND TAKING A REAL
THREAT TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND THEIR RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS OF
THANK YOU MA'AM AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING THIS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SENATOR
. WELL THANK YOU I THANK YOU
BOTH ALL THREE- I IN MY COMMENT
OR QUESTION WAS GOING TO BE
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT SENATOR
GROVE- ASK AND THE ONLY THING I
MIGHT ADD TO THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE HAVING TO CONSIDER IN THIS
TIME OF THE PANDEMIC- WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF. VIDEO CONFERENCE
AND IN TERMS OF THE TRAININGS.
IF- ALE TRANSITIONS BACK TO IN
PERSON TRAININGS DO YOU THINK
YOU MIGHT ARE CONSIDERED
RETAINING THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
OPTION FOR PEOPLE WHO WOULD
PREFER REMOTE TRAINING IS THAT
AN OPTION YOU MIGHT CONSIDER
MOVING FORWARD. YES I WILL I
THINK THAT IS A VERY GOOD
DISCUSSION TO HAVE WITH THE
DIRECTOR I THINK HE IS OPEN TO
ANYTHING THAT SERVES THE PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
DEFINITELY OF THAT I THINK WILL
BE ON THE TABLE FOR DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU I THINK WE HAVE ALL
THOUGHT AND LEARN NEW WAYS TO
PARTICIPATE BUT GIVE THE PUBLIC
THE OPTION AND- I HAVE TO SAY
HERE AND- MIKE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES ALREADY OBVIOUSLY-
I THINK THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
EASIEST- THUS FAR. IS A REVIEW
TO THE WORK. THAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO
TO- THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
ARE AT FIRST R. I WILL SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. I AM NOT SEEING
ANYONE I SHOULD PROBABLY GO
AHEAD AND GIVE THAT REMINDER
RIGHT NOW OF THE- PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE. EXCUSE ME THAT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. AND GIVEN
THAT I DO NOT SEE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN PERSON I'M
GOING TO TURN TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE AND- WELCOME OUR
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT CAME A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE FORGIVE ME I
SHOULD HAVE HIT THE SAID THAT WE
WILL START WITH A MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT PLEASE FORGIVE
ME- MEMBERS IN SUPPORT- THE
MODERATOR IS TEEING YOU UP. AND
WALDRON IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
AND- SORRY SORRY MR MODERATOR AT
YOU KNOW I'M OFF MY RHYTHM TODAY
OBVIOUSLY THAT WENT SO QUICKLY-
I WANT TO REMIND WITNESSES- THAT
WHEN YOU SPEAK I NEED YOU TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOUR%
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT
CLEARLY WERE AYE TAKING CALLS IN
SUPPORT. AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND MISTER
MODERATOR I WILL NOW TURN IT
BACK TO YOU TO DO YOUR JOB THANK
YOU. ABSOLUTELY DELIGHTED COMMON
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THUNDERSNOW
WINNING Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
MOMENT- WE WOULD COME BACK INTO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE HERE
TO TAKE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION NO ONE
HAS COME INTO THE HEARING ROOM-
SO I SEE NO ONE APPROACHING THE
PODIUM TO- REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION SO MISTER MODERATOR
LET ME COME BACK TO YOU NOW FOR
TWO T. FOLKS UP WHO MAY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN THE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
WINNING Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW
MOMENTS FOR OUR NEXT APPOINTEE
HAVE BEEN. GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION I WANT TO BRING
IT BACK AND SEE WHICH OF MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD LIKE TO SENATOR
GROW WOULD LIKE TO SOMEONE MAKE
A MOTION. AND SECONDARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HELLO ZERO
FIVE. KAMLAGER I KAMLAGER II
LAYERED BATES. ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE ON CALL THREE MISGUIDED THAT
WILL BE ON CALL SO THAT SENATOR
LAYER CAN WEIGH IN AND I THINK
YOU ARE HEARD OUR VICE CHAIR SAY
THAT SHE HAD TO LEAVE BUT DOES
SHE WOULD BE IN SUPPORT WHEN
THIS MOVES TO THE FLOOR- YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE HER SUPPORT IS- WHAT
SHE MEANT. AND THOUGH WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR
LAYERED TO- VOTE AND WITH THAT
WE EXTEND OUR CONGRATULATIONS-
IT SEEMS LIKELY THIS IS GOING TO
MOVE TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONFIRMATION CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE- I'M GOING TO SEE IF WE
NEED TO TAKE A BREAK OR NOT AND
NOPE I AM HEARING AND SEEING
FROM OUR INCREDIBLE COURT
REPORTER I KNOW THAT SHE IS
READY TO CONTINUE. SO I'M GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD AND UNDER ITEM
ONE B. R. GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AT THE
APPOINTMENT OF VIRGINIA.
MCDANIEL AND I'M PRETTY SURE I
JUST SAID THAT WRONG SO YOU'LL
CORRECT ME AND FORGIVE ME I
HOPE- AND THIS IS AN APPOINTMENT
TO THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL- I'M GOING TO INVITE YOU
TO- INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE ORG KNOWLEDGE ANYONE
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE IN YOUR
OPENING. REMARKS ON. AND THEN WE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ASK QUESTIONS OR
MAKE COMMENTS SO LET ME JUST SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
WELCOME. THANK YOU HELLO CARE
ATKINS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS VIRGINIA
MIDWAY YEAH AND I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
AND THEN SHARED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MYSELF. BUT FIRST I'D LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE I BELIEVE MY
FATHER- MAY BE WATCHING WITH MY
SISTER FROM HIS HOSPITAL BED. AT
DOCTORS MEDICAL CENTER MY
HUSBAND WHO'S DONE SOMEWHERE
HERE IN IN OUR HOUSE AND- MY TWO
COLLEAGUES. OF LUIS MOLINA AND
CAMPAIGNING. I AM THE DAUGHTER
OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS WHO LIVED
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FROM CHUCK ON
MEXICO IN SEARCH OF A BETTER
LIFE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES. I
WAS THEIR FIRST AMERICAN BORN
CHILD. I AM A GRADUATE OF
BURBANK HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GRADUATE
FROM COLLEGE RECEIVING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM CSU
STANISLAUS IN COMMUNICATIONS. I
STARTED MY CAREER WITH
STANISLAUS COUNTY AT THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER. AND
EVENTUALLY WENT ON TO START MY
OWN COMPANY. AFTER TWELVE YEARS
OF PUBLIC SERVICE. I AM NOW A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER OR ENTREPRENEUR
AND COMMUNITY LEADER IN MY
COMMUNITY HAVING SERVED BOTH AS
A COUNCIL MEMBER AND MAYOR OF MY
HOMETOWN OF RIVERBANK
CALIFORNIA. I WAS APPOINTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA BOATING AND
WATERWAYS COMMISSION IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY THEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN. AND SERVED TWO TERMS. I
AM VERY EXCITED TO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR HE SENT TO
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
IT IS TRULY AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE ON THIS
COUNCIL WHICH IS UNLIKE ANY
OTHER LOCAL STATE OR FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT HAS A PLAN TO WHICH
SHE WATER RELIABILITY. AND
PROTECTING THE ECOSYSTEM I
CONSIDER THIS APPOINTMENT TO BE
A VERY CHALLENGING ASSIGNMENT.
BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
WATER ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT BE SOLVED EASILY HOWEVER I
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS A
TREMENDOUSLY WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAKE PROGRESS AS
I FEEL THAT MY BACKGROUND AND
WORK AS A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
ADVOCATE AND COMMUNICATIONS
SPECIALIST WILL HELP BUILD MORE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH KEY COMMUNITY
GROUPS IN THE DELTA. AND AMONG
THOSE WHO DEPEND ON THE DELTA.
TO EXPAND THE ENGAGEMENT AND
INCLUSION OF GROUPS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN HISTORICALLY INCLUDED
IN THE PAST IN DELTA DISCUSSIONS
AND DECISIONS. MUCH HAS BEEN
GIVEN TO ME AND TO MY FAMILY
FROM THIS WONDERFUL COUNTRY AND
STATE AND THAT IS WHAT PROPELS
ME TO WANT TO GET BACK INTO
SERVING MY COMMUNITY. I AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING A FRUITFUL
DISCUSSION WITH YOU AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON ME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS MATURING YOU KNOW AND THANK
YOU FOR HELPING ME. LEARN TO SAY
YOUR NAME OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE BEEN
BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE BEFORE.
FIVE FOR APPOINTMENT- I HOPE
pYOUR FATHER IS DOING WELL- SO.
LET ME- TURN TO. SENATOR COM
LONGER AND SEE IF YOU WANT TO
START US OFF IN TERMS TO YOUR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM CHAIR AND-
IT'S A PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU
HERE. MISTER MUD WHEN YOU KNOW I
ALSO APOLOGETIC FOR NOT BEING
ABLE TO- HAVE MY SCHEDULE WORK
OUT TODAY FOR US TO- CHAT
BEFOREHAND. BUT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO READ THE
MATERIALS. AND YOUR RESPONSES TO
THE QUESTIONS AND- VERY HAPPY
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
WANT TO DO I THINK YOU'RE
IMMENSELY QUALIFIED FOR IT YOU
KNOW I AM. FROM LOS ANGELES AND
REPRESENTS- AND URBAN DISTRICT.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND-
WATER IS A BIG THING NOT ONLY
FOR THE STATE. BUT FOR L. A. N.
YOU KNOW WE GET CALLED A LOT OF
NAMES FOR THE WATER THAT WE USE.
AND JUST WANTED TO. GET YOUR
TAKE ON HOW YOU BALANCE THE
NEEDS OF. YOU KNOW FOUR MILLION
DELTA RESIDENTS WHO OPPOSE THE
TUNNELS ECOLOGICALLY UNIVERSES.
ALMOST TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE WHO
NEED A RELIABLE AND SAFE WATER
SOURCE YOU KNOW- BEING ON THIS
COUNCIL IS ABOUT MANAGING
MULTIPLE PRIORITIES THAT HAVE
YOU KNOW THE SAME OR EQUAL VALUE
AND JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON. THOSE SEEMINGLY
CONTRADICTORY NEEDS AND- YOUR
APPROACH TO BALANCING THEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR. SO I'D LIKE TO
JUST PROMISED THIS BY LETTING
YOU KNOW THAT YOU KNOW I
OBVIOUSLY WE ON THE WATER- WATER
IS THE VERY ESSENCE OF OUR LIFE.
AND IS A FORMER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER FOR CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND WE'RE TRANSFORM I SAW THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF NITRATES IN
DRINKING WATER IN COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS LAWRENCE. EVERY DAY
MONTEREY TRACK WHERE I WORK HE
AND I WHERE WERE HAVING DEBATE
THEIR BABIES AND BOTTLED WATER
AND SO. I BECAUSE THE TAP WATER
WAS SO CONTAMINATED. SO I DO
FEEL THAT IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
WE FIND A BALANCE FOR US TO HAVE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER WHILE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE NEED TO
HELP SUSTAIN OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE. BY PROVIDING WATER. THAT
HELPS US TO GROW OUR INVESTABLE
CENTER. PAGE WE DEPEND FOR A DAY
LIFE. WE DO HAVE- OBVIOUSLY
WATER QUALITY RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE DELTA PLAN BUT MOSTLY THIS
IS IN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND REGIONAL WATER BOARDS
SO I APPROACH. THIS TASK IN THIS
ROLE- OBVIOUSLY LEANING ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE IS
AVAILABLE TO US- ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT- OF COURSE ARE
INDEPENDENT SCIENCE BOARD AND
OUR LEAD PLAINTIFF- DOCTOR
LARSON. BUT I DO ALWAYS. I FEEL
THAT IT'S A BALANCE IF YOU WILL
BUT ALWAYS ENSURING THAT- WE
NEVER COMPROMISED DRINKING WATER
FOR ANYBODY I THINK THAT THAT IS
A FUNDAMENTAL- PRIVILEGE THAT WE
SHOULD ALL HAVE THE WORLD THE
RIGHT TO CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER- IN OUR STATE. WELL I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE IN
AS YOU WERE TALKING I WAS
THINKING BACK ACTUALLY TO MY
TOUR. WITH THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT AND THE AMAZING
WORK I THINK THEY'RE DOING TO BE
A- GOOD PARTNER IN HOW WE USE
WATER HOW WE RECLAIM WATER HOW
WE- ACQUIRED. BE MORE JUDICIOUS-
WITH IT BECAUSE IT IS A FINITE
RESOURCE IN SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD- YOU KNOW TAKE CARE OF IN
A IN IN A PRECIOUS MANNER. AND
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
DEEPLY RELIANT UPON I MEAN YOU
KNOW. TO MY COLLEAGUE. FROM-
WELL TO MY COLLEAGUE TO THE
RIGHT OF ME- IT'S A THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ARM TO THOSE IN THE AG INDUSTRY
WHO ARE WORKING DAY AND NIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE GROWING
THE KIND OF SUSTENANCE THAT WE
CAN SELL NOT ONLY TO
CALIFORNIANS BUT TO FOLKS ACROSS
THE WORLD IS A PRECIOUS
COMMODITY AND IT'S PART OF A
VERY IMPORTANT ECONOMY- AND YET
THERE ARE FOLKS ACROSS. THE
STATE AND OTHER PARTS THAT RELY
ON IT NOT NECESSARILY FOR
BUSINESS BUT TO LIVE. AND
SUSTAIN AND SO HOW WE BALANCE
ALL OF THOSE NEEDS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT- TAKING ADVANTAGE
OR MARGINALIZING GROUPS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I FEEL LIKE
YOUR VOICE WILL BE ADDED TO THE
DISCUSSIONS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
IN THAT SPACE AND I WILL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR BREAUX. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESSURE WELCOME MR
DOING L. M. TODAY COMMITTEE I
KNOW THIS IS A RECONFIRMATION
FOR YOU- I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES'S
COMMENTS- ESPECIALLY SINCE I
ACTUALLY HAPPEN TO REPRESENT-
TWO OF THE TOP FOOD PRODUCE FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD NOT JUST THE STATE. AND
FROM KERN BEING TO AND TULARE
BRING THREE. BUT I A BIT. I DO
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT- BALLOTS
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES DID I DO APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THAT YOU DID HAVE SOME TYPE
OF THAT GREEN BRINGING IN THAT
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. M. AND I
DO APPRECIATE VERY VERY MUCH
THAT YOU ARE A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER SO YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
AND SOMETIMES- MY COMMENTS ARE
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS FOR YOU
KNOW THIRTY ONE YEARS IN THE
STATE IN SPITE OF THE STATE
SOMETIMES BECAUSE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO FOLLOW WAITED
HERE TOO. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCE IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS YOU
MENTIONED- THAT WATER
RELIABILITY AND SO AS WE
MENTIONED THAT IT MADE ME THINK
OF THE- ABOVEGROUND STORAGE IN
THAT WATER RELIABILITY AND
COMMENT IS IT YOUR OPINION THAT
WE WOULD NEED MORE ABOVE GROUND
STORAGE. YOU KNOW. I THINK THAT
THERE IS- A LOT OF EMPHASIS PUT
ON STORAGE AND ALTHOUGH I DO.
LEAVE THAT WE DO NEED-
ADDITIONAL STORAGE I ALSO
BELIEVE IN THE NOTION OF
CONSERVATION RECYCLING AND
MAKING MORE INVESTMENTS WHEN IT
COMES TO WATER SUPPLY SO I DON'T
THINK THAT STORAGE IS THE ONLY
ANSWER I THINK THAT THERE'S GOT
TO BE MORE WAYS- AGAIN
INCLUDING. CONSERVATION
RECYCLING AND MAKING ANY AND ALL
INVESTMENTS POSSIBLE WHEN IT
COMES TO WATER SUPPLY. THANK
YOU- HOW WOULD YOU BALANCE THE
NEEDS FOLLOWING UP ON MY
COMMENT- THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES HOW
WOULD YOU BALANCE THE NEEDS OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- OF
LOS ANGELES GETS A LOT OF THEIR
WATER- FROM YOU KNOW THE DATE
BAY AREA DELTA AREA. IN THE
CONVEYANCES STEM AND SO DOES THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WE START CONSTITUENTS
THAT DON'T HAVE RUNNING WATER.
MYSELF MISS CAN BE- OPUS HER
TADO- OUR CONSTITUENTS TURN
THERE ARE SOME OF THEM THAT TURN
ON THE FAUCET THERE'S NO WATER
THAT COMES. AND DOES DOES THE
COUNTY OR THE STATE- I THINK
IT'S A CITY BUT THEY DELIVER-
WATER TO THEIR HOUSES IN THESE
BIG BLACK- CONTAINERS EVERY WEEK
SO THAT THERE'S SOME TYPE OF
WATER SO. HOW DO YOU BALANCE THE
NEEDS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- THAT RECEIVE THEIR
DRINKING WATER FROM THE DELTA
WITH THE INTEREST OF THE DELTA
COMMUNITY. COLLEGE MEN'S AND R.
FOUR MILLION STRONG. GREAT
QUESTION AND- AGAIN WITH ALL
TRANSPARENCY IDEA. TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES- THAT DID HAVE TO
GET. THEIR WATER. AND
TRANSPORTED IN A BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T DRINK IT THEY COULDN'T
OPEN THE FAUCET LIKE I CAN LIKE
YOU CAN AND BE ABLE TO DRINK OUT
OF THE TAP- I THINK THAT IT'S-
CRITICAL THAT WE WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND IS A MEMBER
OF THE COUNCIL I'M SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT THE STATE AND NOT ONE
REGION. YES AS I READ- WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED FOR US TO
DO. I BELIEVE THAT THE DELTA%
PROTECTION COMMISSION EXISTS TO
BE ABLE TO ELEVATE THOSE VOICES
AND THOSE NEEDS- AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO WORK.
VERY STRATEGICALLY WITH OUR
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES AND IT
THRILLS ME AND I'M SO GRATEFUL
THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN. LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND THAT
BEING SUPERVISOR DONNA TOLD ME
SO I THINK THAT IT'S THAT
BALANCE THAT DELICATE BALANCE-
BUT FOR ME I TAKE IT ONE STEP
FURTHER JUST KNOWING THAT. I DO
COME FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
KNOWING THAT I DID REPRESENT AND
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SO MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT NEEDED THAT
PRECIOUS DRINKING WATER- I WILL
ALWAYS CONTINUE TO BE A VOICE
AND MAKE CERTAIN. THAT
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES OF THE BOYS AND THE
ADVOCACY WHEN IT COMES TO CLEAN
DRINKING WATER IN CALIFORNIA. I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH LOCAL- COMMUNITIES IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
RELIABLE CLEAN DRINKING WATER- I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN YEARS SINCE SOME OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO TURN
ON THEIR- FAUCET AND GET WATER
AND SO I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO WHAT YOU WILL DO. I'M IN THE
BALANCE TO HELP THOSE
CONSTITUENTS. I- I ALSO HAVE A
CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT THE ROLE OF
THE COUNCIL WOULD PLAY IN
ASSURING THAT BALANCED APPROACH
IS WOULD BE PROTECTIVE FOR THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. AS WELL AS-
HABITAT ENHANCEMENT. I SOMETIMES
THINK THAT IT'S AN AT ALL COST
FOR HABITAT ENHANCEMENT- AND
THERE'S NOT VERY MUCH WAIT AND-
PUT ON OUR ECONOMY. IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO SURVIVE SO CAN YOU
TELL ME THE BALANCED APPROACH
THAT SHE WOULD HAVE IN THOSE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS. SURE WELL
RECOGNIZING AGAIN THAT I WAS
BORN AND RAISED HERE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND RECOGNIZING.
THAT THE DELTA- IS. THE HEART OF
IT CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
MONEY IT'S I'M SORRY THE DELTA
IS IN THE HEART OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE COMMODITY AND- IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN I BELIEVE
ACCOUNT FOR FORTY FIVE BILLION
IN ANNUAL SALES SO I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT. THE DELTA PLACE
HE CRITICAL AND PIVOTAL ROLE- TO
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND SO.
ENSURING THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH HE STAKEHOLDERS. AND MAKING
SURE THAT VOICES. RESPECTED AND
- ARE ALL AT THE TABLE THAT'S
HOW I TRY TO APPROACH THIS AND
DOING THE BEST THAT I CAN IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE A
CONVENER. THAT WE ARE TAKING
AGAIN AS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
WITH THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE
AVAILABLE TO US. ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES OBVIOUSLY
WORKING WITH OUR INDEPENDENT
SCIENCE BOARD AND WITH OUR LEAD
SCIENTIST- AND AGAIN MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE AS INDEPENDENT. AND
IN OUR SCIENTIFIC VIEWS- AND
THAT THIS IS NOT POLITICAL OR
GETTING POLITICAL PREFERENCE TO
ANYONE BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING RIGHT BY OUR STATE.
AND BY ALL THAT ARE SERVED BY
ADULTS. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH AND- I
JUST A YOU KNOW AGAIN THE TOP
THREE FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN
THE WORLD OR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHICH YOU GREW UP IN. AS
THEIR SEVERAL COMMITTEES I THINK
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED AND
SOMETHING COMMODITIES WHICH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY GIRLS 99% OF. SO
I MEAN IF YOU WERE GOING TO
START BRING PISTACHIOS- CUTIES
ARE ALL THOSE THINGS IN ANOTHER
LOCATION AT THE UNITED STATES OR
ANOTHER COUNTRY IT WOULD TAKE
TIME FOR THOSE TREES MATURE TO
PROVIDE THOSE PRODUCTS. OR THOSE
COMMODITIES AND- IS THERE A
BACKUP PLAN I'M REALLY
INTERESTED TO KNOW IF THERE IS A
BACK UP PLAN FROM THESE AGENCIES
AND WHEN I SAY BACKUP PLAN I
MEAN THAT. IN OUR FARMERS AND
GROWERS THE CARD IS ZERO
ALLOCATION FOR WATER LAST YEAR I
DON'T ANTICIPATE IT BEING HIRED
THIS YEAR. AND FROM THE STATE
WATER PROJECT WHICH IS I KNOW
THIS IS NOT THE DELTA- BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE STRATEGIC COUNCIL.
BUT WE ARE LOOKING AT WATER
DISTRIBUTION AND IS ARE YOU
AWARE EVER DO YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S A BACK UP PLAN ON WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GET FOOD FOR FOOD
SECURITY ISSUES FOR NOT ONLY.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT THE AND-
TIRED UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
THERE ARE A BACK UP PLAN THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT. IF WE'RE NOT
GONNA ALLOW FARMERS TO HAVE
WATER TO GROW FOOD. SO YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT THAT'S PART OF THE-
YOU KNOW AS AND REMEMBER I'M I'M
KIND OF THE NEWBIE HERE AND-
IT'S RECESSES I CAN'T BUT I
THINK THAT KIND OF GOES- TO THE
QUESTION OF HOW. REDUCING THE
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA AND WHO
WHO IS GOING TO GET- WATER IN
WHO IS NOT GOING TO GET WATER.
AND AS I LOOKING AS I. HAVE I
HAVE BEEN LEARNING IF YOU WELL
OVER THE LAST SEVEN MONTHS SINCE
HAVE SINCE I'VE BEEN APPOINTED.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THE DELTA PLAN
HAS A REGULATION. NOT REQUIRING
- YOU KNOW FOR CERTAIN COVERED
ACTIONS THAT LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM A WATER
PROJECT MUST. READ MUST
DEMONSTRATE THEIR REDUCED
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA AND TO DO
SO THEY HAVE TO SHOW THEIR LOCAL
URBAN AND ADD WATER MANAGEMENT
PLANS. AND SO I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
SHOWED US HOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
SHOW THE REDUCED RELIANCE- BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES. HAS THE
GUIDANCE AND IS WORKING WITH US-
IN IN TERMS OF HOW- THESE
PROJECTS ARE GOING TO BE
COMPLYING WITH THE REDUCED
RELIANCE AND- REPORTING
MECHANISMS. I DO OBVIOUSLY YOU.
EMPATHETICALLY UNDERSTAND THAT
AND AGAIN HAVING BEEN RAISED IN
AGONY- MY PARENTS WORKED IN AG I
AM A CHAMPION IF YOU WILL FOR
ADD- AND RECOGNIZING THAT. WE
NEED TO DO MORE- AND WE HAVE TO
DO MORE TO PROVIDE AND THAT
WATER TESTS WITH OUR FRESH FRESH
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES- BUT I
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME. MEDIATION BANDEL
WORK- SOME GUIDANCE FOR HOW WE
CAN ALL COME AT THIS TOGETHER
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT REDUCING
EVERYBODY'S RELIANCE- AND
FINDING OTHER WAYS. OF YOU KNOW
SO THAT EVERYBODY HAS ITS FAIR
SHARE BUT WE CAN'T COMPROMISE IN
MY OPINION WE CAN'T COMPROMISE-
MUCH OF WHAT. LEADS US ON A
DAILY BASIS. AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS I YES I DO I JUST
I THINK THAT PEOPLE FOCUS A LOT
WHICH IS THERE IS A PORTION OF
THIS YOU KNOW. JOBS FARMWORKERS
JOBS YOU KNOW OUR FARMS THAT
HAVE BEEN THERE FOREVER AND BUT
I THINK WE'RE COMING TO A POINT
WITH THE WATER RESTRICTIONS AND-
YOU KNOW THAN NOT BEING ABLE TO
PUMP GROUNDWATER. AND SOME OTHER
STUFF FOR HOW FARMER SURVIVED I
KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE FOR
HALLOWEEN- HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
THIS YEAR ALONE AND SO. I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE FUTURE
AND FOOD SECURITY ISSUES AND-
YOU KNOW WE'RE GETTING THIS FROM
VISA I KNOW WE CAN GET THEM FROM
OUR SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR THAT
MEXICO I KNOW WE CAN GET FOOD
THAT WE GROW IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FROM VENEZUELA. BUT I
HAVE A HUGE CONCERN ABOUT FOOD
SECURITY ISSUES AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WITHOUT WATER. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WANT TO ADD
THAT THERE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
PLANS PUT TOGETHER SO THAT
PEOPLE DON'T RELY ON THE ON THE
DELTA FOR WATER RESOURCES. AT
BUT IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS BEING REDUCED
FROM WATER FROM ALL SITES
WHETHER IT'S GROUND WATER THAT
DELTA THE CONVENIENCE SUSPEND
SURFACE WATER WHICH THEY HAD A
CONTRACT TO AGREE WITH I MEAN.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT I THINK THAT
WE'RE NOT LOOKING LONG TERM AND
F. AND- HERE THAT MAYBE BECAUSE
WHEN I'M NOT GONNA SAY I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S BECAUSE OF TERM
LIMITS AND YOU KNOW IN. YOU KNOW
TWENTY YEARS ALL OF US WILL NOT
BE HERE BUT I BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES FOR FOOD SECURITY
IF WE DON'T FIX THIS SITUATION
SPECIFICALLY. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY REDUCE THE. BALLOT WROTE
. AND S. I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
HAVE THE BACK. OF A SPECIAL
GROWING TO IN THIS. VALLEY AND
BEING AN IMMIGRANT AND BEING IT
YOU KNOW YOUR FAMILY FOR YOUR
YOU KNOW FOR BEING HERE FROM.
IMMIGRATING HERE. AND FOR A
BETTER WAY OF LIFE- I THINK
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE COME HERE IS
BECAUSE THEY WANT A BETTER WAY
OF LIFE. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOU. AS A BUT I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. A SEAT. IN
THE FUTURE- AND ABOUT THE THINGS
THAT I DISCUSS WITH YOU TODAY. I
WOULD LOVE THAT SENATOR WELCOME
BACK AND THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR THOSE COMMENTS. HAVE A
WONDERFUL DAY MA'AM AND THANK
YOU FOR DOING WHAT YOU DO. THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE SENATOR LAYERED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MMHM AND-
THANK YOU FOR MEETING WITH ME- I
REALLY ENJOYED THE MEETING AND I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP I PARTICULARLY
ENJOYED SENATOR COM LONGER. THE
FIRM TO SENATOR GROVE AS THE
PERSON ON THE RIGHT AND SO. I AM
GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON QUESTIONS
FROM THE PERSON ON MY LEFT-
SENATOR GROW BECAUSE I THINK
THAT I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
ISSUE BALANCE. OF THE LAW THAT
CREATED THE STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
IN TRYING TO BOUNCE IN THE WALL
IT SAID THERE WILL BE DOOR GOALS
OF WATER RELIABILITY. AND
HABITAT PROTECTION. IN IT AS I
USED TO SAY IN A PRIOR
INCARNATION AND EVERYBODY'S
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO ONE OF THE
TWO GIRLS. AND I THINK IT WAS
DESIGNED TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SO IF YOU WERE
REVIEWING THE PLAN THAT IS FRONT
OF YOU AND THE COVERED ACTIONS
WHICH IS YOUR STEP TOWARD QUORUM
. HOW ARE YOU GONNA REFER THE
BALANCE THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE
LAW. TO MAKE SURE THAT HABITAT
PROTECTION IS ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED AND WATER RELIABILITY
IS ADEQUATELYPROTECTED HOW CAN
I MAKE SURE DOESN'T TIP ONE WAY
ORANOTHER AND WHAT YOU DO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SENATOR LARRY
AND YES IT WAS A PLEASURE TO
SPEAK WITH YOU EARLIER TODAY.
WELL I REALLY TRULY FEEL THAT
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL-
IS IN A- GREAT POSITION AND
PROBABLY THE ONLY POSITION TO BE
ABLE TO PUSH HARD- AGAIN ON IT
THE REDUCING THE RELIANCE- AS A
STATUTORY POLICY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT- AND WE
SHARED AND DISCUSSED A LITTLE
BIT IN OUR CALL EARLIER TODAY.
IN THAT WE ARE NOT A SCIENTIST
BUT WE ARE ALSO INDEPENDENT
BOARD ITSELF I ALWAYS WANT TO
LOOK AT IT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF WHAT MAKES SENSE AND CLEARLY
WE HAVE SOME. AREAS OF CONCERN
THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT THE
ECOSYSTEM- THAT THAT WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT BUT IT'S ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE AREN'T DOING.
THE VERY BEST THAT WE CAN YOU
KNOW REDUCING THE RELIANCE. S
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOU AS WELL. IT'S THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IS A LONG
TERM PLANNING AGENCY AND AS I
LEARN MORE. I DO SEE THAT WE
HAVE SOME. SOME DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE MAKING- IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE AND I DO TAKE A LOOK
AT DELTA DOUBTS IS PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT NOW IN. WE
HAVE DONE A BOULDER ABILITY
ASSESSMENT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
DONE AND SO PART OF THAT USED TO
INCLUDE AGAIN THE SOCIAL BOTH
VOTER ABILITIES THAT EXIST. AND
LOOKING AT. ME AT THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE IDENTIFIED-
TO FIND AGAIN THE MOST PRACTICAL
AND EFFECTIVE AND THAT
ADAPTATION STRATEGIES AND I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF WHERE
WE'RE- I'M GOING WITH YOUR- WITH
YOUR COMMENTS- I THINK THAT
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A LOT THAT I'M
GOING TO BE LEARNING AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING THESE.
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AND- SOME
OF THE OTHER SENATORS THAT HAVE
ALWAYS ALREADY ASKED FOR ME TO
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. I DO SEE
. THAT THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL WAS CREATED FOR A
PURPOSE- BACK PURPOSE CONTINUES
TO INVOLVED BECAUSE THE SCIENCE
IS NOT STAGNANT AND AS I LEARNED
MORE- AND AS WE- ARE APPROACH ON
A MONTHLY BASIS WITH REPORTS
FROM. INDEPENDENT SCIENCE BOARD.
THE BILL SCIENCE SCIENTIST IF
YOU WILL TO SHARE WITH LEYVA
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF. ARE GIVING
US AGAIN THE APPROACHES- AND THE
THOUGHT OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR IN THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE. THEN I WON'T
EXCUSE ME I WILL ENJOY HAVING
THOSE TALKS WITH YOU I'D I DO
HAVE SOME KNOWLEDGE ON THE ISSUE
AND HE SORT OF WALKED INTO MY
OTHER QUESTION BECAUSE YOU SAID
THAT. THE DISTRICT COUNCIL WAS
CREATED FOR A PURPOSE YOU ALSO
SAID IT WAS A LONG TERM PLANNING
AGENCY. IT WAS ACTUALLY CREATED
TO REVIEW THE DELTA PLAN. AND I
DON'T THINK IT WAS DESIGNED TO
BE A LONG TERM AGENCY. ONCE IT
COMPLETED ITS OBLIGATION TO
REVIEW THE PLANS. AND WHAT SEEMS
TO BE HAPPENING IS THE THING
THAT HAPPENS WITH SOME
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IF THEY FIND
A WAY TO PERPETUATE THEMSELVES.
AND TO KEEP GROWING AND SO. ARM
I JUST GATHERED IN OUR TALK THIS
MORNING IT IT TOTALLY AGREE WITH
ME. BUT OUR I THOUGHT MAYBE IT
TALK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE IT I
THANK THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
REVISIT THIS IF IT. IF IT MEETS
ITS ORIGINAL STATUTORY DIRECTION
FOR ITS PURPOSE- WOULD YOU
COMMENT ON THAT. YES SO AND THAT
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING- AFTER WE
CHATTED EARLIER TODAY AND THAT
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
WAS IN FACT. A PART OF THE- PART
OF THE I GUESS PLAN WITH
EXPERIENCE PROJECT BUT MY AND
YOU'RE GONNA HELP ME YOUR HELP
EDUCATE ME AND INFORMED ME-
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS MORE
THAN JUST THE CONVEYANCE PROJECT
BUT IT WAS TO ALSO PROVIDE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY. FOR ALL
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING TO
COME BEFORE US AND- AS I AS I
HAD THAT CONVERSATION WITH YOU
EARLIER TODAY- THE OTHER PART
THAT POPPED INTO MY MIND IS WHO
ELSE WOULD TAKE THE ROLE OF THE
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IF WE
PRETTY MUCH COMPLETE. BECAUSE I
SEE THAT THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL IS REALLY THE ONLY
AGENCY AT LEAST AS QUIET AS I
SEE IT YOU MAY DISAGREE AND I
AND AGAIN I WOULD WELCOME THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. OF WHO
HAS THE VISION AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY IN ENSURING THAT
WE DO HAVE THAT BALANCE OF THE
CALL WE WILL BUILD FOR BOTH THE
EAGLE RESTORATION AND THE
RELIANCE ON WATER. SO YOU'RE
CORRECT I MAY BE MISINFORMED BUT
I WELCOME THAT CONVERSATION
FURTHER CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
MALHAR WAS CHANNELING SENATOR
GROWTH BECAUSE USUALLY I COUNT
ON OR- TO SAY THAT AN AGENCY
MIGHT HAVE OUTLIVED ITS PURPOSE
AND WE NEED TO REVISIT IT AND SO
I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD DO IT ON
HER BEHALF AND MIGHT BE HALF. IT
IN THIS HEARING THIS TIME ARE IN
THE IN THE ERROR AS I SAID
EARLIER TODAY. THERE'S THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL WITH THE
DOCTOR CONSERVANCY THERE'S A
DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION
THERE'S A WHLE HOST OF AGENCIES
AND- I THINK THIS HAD A PURPOSE
AND WHEN IT REALIZES ITS PURPOSE
I THINK IT'S TIME TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. ABOUT WHAT WORKS
IN THE GOVERNMENT'S OR WHAT IS
NECESSARY BETWEEN ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. THAT EXIST
BUT BOB I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND. I WILL VOTE FOR
CONFIRMATION. COOLEY TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER EARLIER
AND I. AGREE WITH WHATYOU'RE-
HAVING HAD SERVED IN THE- IN A
WATER RESCUE MISSION AND HAVING
SEEN HOW IT WAS- AT THAT TIME
GOVERNOR. BROWN WAS
RESTRUCTURING CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND- TRYING
TO STREAMLINE I DO TRULY
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU AND HE DID
HAVE AN AGENT WORKING FOR HIM
THAT STREAMLINED EDITING AND
WATER WAYS INTO THE STATE PARKS
DEPARTMENT. OH MY GOODNESS. IT'S
ALWAYS A GOOD TO HAVE THE FORMER
SECRETARY HERE HI WHO WHO
OBVIOUSLY KNOWS SO MUCH ABOUT
ALL THESE ISSUES- SENATOR
LAYERED THANK YOU- I'VE ENJOYED
LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS- IN
MY- NUMBER OF YEARS HERE IN THE
SENATE I'VE SERVED ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE BEFORE I WAS PRO TEMAS
A MEMBER AND- HAVE LISTENED TO
THESE APPOINTMENTS TO- TO THIS
BODY. MULTIPLE TIMES. AND HAVE
ASKED THE CO EQUAL GOALS AND
THE- YOU KNOW AND IT'S BEEN A
CHANGING LANDSCAPE FRANKLY
BETWEEN GOVERNORS- CLEARLY-
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES CLIMATE
CHANGE DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS
SO TO YOUR POINT OF. IS IT TIME
FOR SOMETHING TO BE GONE IT'S
KIND OF HARD TO SAY THANK
GOODNESS THE SCIENTIST IN THE
PANEL ARE OR THEIR TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE THAT. THE EXPERTISE
AND THEN OF COURSE I WAS GOING
TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE-
VULNERABILITY- ASSESSMENT BUT-
YOU COMMENTED ON THAT AND-
SENATOR LEHRER DID AS WELL. I
YOU KNOW AND THEN YOU'VE GOT
SOME FOLKS HERE WHO REPRESENT
VERY DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
STATE. FOLKS AS FAR AWAY AS LOS
ANGELES TWO SENATOR COM AUGERS-
COMMENT AND SAY DIEGO HAVE
WEIGHED IN ON THIS AND THEY HAVE
OPINIONS ABOUT WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN IN THE DELTA. AS FAR AWAY
AS YOU GO AND WHAT THEY THOUGHT
ABOUT ONE TUNNEL VERSUS TWO
TUNNELS VERSUS- SO MANY OF THESE
ISSUES- I DON'T REALLY THINK I
CAN ADD TO THIS CONVERSATION
MUCH MORE THAN HAS BEEN- STATED
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE UP AND DOWN THE STATE OR
ARE AWARE OF THIS ISSUE AND HAVE
CONCERNS AND- CONTINUE TO
MONITOR- HOW THIS IS GOING TO
PROCEED AND SO I THINK. THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD IS YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES. THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE FROM CENTRAL
VALLEY- YOU KNOW. IS IMPORTANT I
MEAN IT IS A COMMUNITY THAT'S
IMPACTED THE DELTA IS IMPACTED
BY DECISIONS WE MAKE. AND SO- I
WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK I
THINK YOU'RE- MORE THAN
QUALIFIED- IN ANY NUMBER OF WAYS
TO STEP INTO THIS ROLE FROM YOUR
WORK AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL- IN
A COMMUNITY- THAT'S IMPACTED- AS
WELL AS THE OTHER WORK YOU'VE
DONE. SO I SUPPORT YOU ARM
ABSOLUTELY. BUT IT THESE ARE
CHANGING- ISSUES RELATED. TO THE
DELTA AND CHANGING POLITICS
FRANKLY LET'S JUST BE CLEAR- SO
I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK AND-
WE WILL. HERE IT DID YOU WANNA
YOU LEAN FORWARD CENTER LAYERED
HI ABOUT THE PUBLIC AND I WAS
REALLY OVER. WE NEVER FORGET
ABOUT PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I'D
THANK YOU SENATOR I WILL BE
READY TO LOOK YOUR WAY- AFTER WE
TAKE THAT PUBLIC COMMENT. I
THINK. WE I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE I DO AND- ALL THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- HOW WE HAVE
ENOUGH WATER- WHAT ARE THE YOU
KNOW DEPENDING UPON WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE DELTA AND HOW IT HAPPENS
HOW ARE WE GOING TO HAVE WATER
RELIABILITY FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE AND- SEE I WAS GET READY
TO WIND DOWN BUT THEN YOU MADE
ME THINK OF YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN SAN DIEGO ON.
CONSERVATION AND WATER RECYCLING
AND STORAGE AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
WE HAVE A GOOD MODEL SORRY WE DO
I HAVE TO BRAG ABOUT SAN DIEGO
BUT IT'S TAKEN A LOT OF WORK AND
IT'S BEEN PAINFUL OF FRANKLY BUT
ARE AT ANY RATE I'M GOING TO
TURN NOW TO THE PUBLIC- THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND
IT IS FAR BEYOND. YOU KNOW JUST
LOOKING AT- ARE YOU KNOW. THE
DELTA IN AND OF ITSELF IT HAS
BROADER- RAMIFICATIONS SO THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK SHARE SHARE
COMMENTS TRULY TRULY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU- SO I
AM GOING TO GO AHEAD BEFORE I.
LOOK IN THE ROOM AND SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLICATION UP
AND GIVE ONE LAST- REMINDER OF
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER. I FEEL LIKE I'M DOING A
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT OUR
I'M SELLING A CAR ONE OF THE
TWO. THAT NUMBER THAT TOLL FREE
NUMBER WHICH IS IMPORTANT FOR
THE PUBLIC IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. AND
WITH THAT- I WOULD INVITE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC UP TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT BUT I SEE NO
ONE HERE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. SO I'M GONNA GO TO OUR
MODERATOR WHO'S BEEN PATIENTLY
STANDING BY TO ASK IF HE WOULD
LIKE TO T. UP. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND AGAINST GIVE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF INDEED THEY
REPRESENT THEIR POSITION. AND
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY MISTER
MODERATOR WELCOME BACK. THANK
YOU IF YOU TO- GO AHEAD AND
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME NOT EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATORS GOING TO GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER QUICKLY OFFLINE THE
PLACE YOU RIGHT BACK IN THE
QUEUE. WE'LL GET TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND I'M SURE
WE'LL GET A NOBODY QUEUEING UP
AT THIS TIME. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH- LET ME. GO AHEAD AND- TAKE
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS NO ONE
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE THAT I WOULD ANTICIPATE
WANTS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SO
LET ME JUST COME RIGHT BACK TO
YOU MISTER MODERATOR AND SEE IF
YOU T<c.cyan>P ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE</c>
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
CONFIRMATION. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL GO AHEAD HIT ONE FILED BY
ZERO AGAIN OPERATE WILL QUICKLY
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
THEN PLEASE WRITE BACK IN THE
QUEUE. HERE NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
MISTER MODERATOR- THANK YOU WE
GAVE YOU AN EASY JOB TODAY BUT I
KNOW THAT IT IS NOT ALWAYS EASY
SO WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR WHAT WE DO
THANK YOU. I AM GOING TO TURN TO
SENATOR LAYER I WOULD MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF MOTION HAS BEEN MADE MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH I GROW BY KAMLAGER
HI LONGER I'D LAYERED. LAYERED I
BATES ATKINS HI ATKINS DIET FOR
THE ZERO IT IS FOUR TWO ZERO
WITH. MY VICE CHAIR NOT OUR
PRESIDENT SO THAT CONFIRMATION
WILL BE FORWARDED TO- THE SENATE
FLOOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONVERSATION AND YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
ATKINS I TRULY APPRECIATE IT AND
THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TRULY TRULY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU AGAIN. SO WITH THAT-
I'M GOING TO ASK THAT WE OPEN
THE ROLE- ON ITEM ONE. A. AND
THAT WAS THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT ODD TO APPEAR.
ELIZABETH HIDING FOR THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. LAYERED ARE
LAYERED BY ORDER ZERO THAT IS
FOUR ZERO THAT WILL BE FORWARDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. I LET ME GO
TO ITEMS TO. C. D. E. AND F.
THESE ARE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR FOR THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
LAYERED. LAYERED I FIVE THREE
pITEM THREE IS THE REFERRAL OF
BILLS OPEN THE ROLE LAYERED.
LAYERED I FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
FIVE TWO ZERO SO I WANNA THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY WE HAVE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. OUR FOR OUR THAT
CONCLUDES TODAY'S AGENDA SO IF
INDIVIDUALS- WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY AND YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS YOU MAY
DO SO AGAIN YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR TESTIMONIES IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU EVERYONE IT WAS- IT
WAS A QUICK DAY BUT IT'S BEEN A
BUSY. BUSY DAY ALREADY SO THANK
YOU ARE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ROLES IS NOW A JERK.